dans quelques instants le président du
Sénat gère à Larcher au terme de ce vote
favorable de la Haute Assemblée en
faveur de la réforme des retraites on va
rappeler ce vote et bien il y a eu 195
votes pour 112 votre compte de sénateur
sur cette réforme de retraite et
j'accueille sur ce plateau le président
du Sénat général Larcher bonsoir bonsoir
merci de venir sur le plateau de Public
Sénat d'abord votre réaction gère à
l'archer au terme de ces 10 jours de
débat ça y est et bien l'une des deux
Chambres du Parlement a voté cette
réforme de retraite je crois que le
Sénat a rempli sa mission
constitutionnelle
dès avant l'ouverture des débats j'avais
dit que je souhaitais vraiment
profondément que nous ayons un débat aux
alliances au bout du débat et au
Parlement après le temps du débat on
délibère et on vote
je crois que c'est une responsabilité
majeure et c'est la responsabilité
du président d'une chambre dans un parc
Le Mans bi-caméral
la seconde des choses c'est que nous
avons
par notre organisation des débats permis
qu'il y ait plus de senteurs de débats
je dois dire alors que nous n'avions que
15 jours alors que l'Assemblée nationale
a 20 jours et sans esprit de concurrence
nous avons presque débattu 30 heures de
plus que l'Assemblée nationale et
examiner les 20 articles de ce texte
au fond le vote de ce soir c'est la
conclusion d'une démarche engagée depuis
plus de quatre ans au Sénat dans une
réflexion de la commission des affaires
sociales
qui depuis quatre ans proposé de
réformer le système de retraite par
répartition pour le sauver pour le
préserver et le cœur du réacteur de ce
texte c'était l'article 7 sur le report
à 64 ans pour lequel j'ai rappelé le
nombre d'interventions de présentation
d'amendement le total c'est plus de 130
donc il y a eu un débat extrêmement
approfondie sur le cœur du réacteur il y
a eu des votes
il va suite à ce vote avoir une
négociation dans ce qu'on appelle la
commission mixte parité entre cette
sénateur sept députés finalement un
dialogue entre la droite et le
gouvernement pour avoir et bien un
accord sur ce texte quels sont les
lignes rouges du Sénat sur cette réforme
des retraites d'abord la CP va avoir
lieu sur le texte du Sénat et non pas le
texte du Gouvernement imaginons que nous
n'ayons pas j'allais dire assurer notre
fonction
CMP aurait eu lieu sur le texte du
Gouvernement sans les apports qui ont
été les apports du Sénat je pense
notamment un certain nombre d'apports
sur les seniors sur l'assurance
vieillesse des aidants sur ce qui a pu
être obtenu aussi au cours des débats je
pense pour les professeurs des écoles
pour les sapeurs-pompiers il va avoir
lieu aussi sur des questions aussi
importantes que par exemple la prise en
compte la prise en compte de l'usure
professionnelle de l'incapacité
professionnelle tous ces jugé là le
Sénat va les porter devant la commission
mixte paritaire
commission mix paritaire s'est a lieu
ouvert de débat entre 7 sénateurs cette
députée pour aboutir un texte qui devra
être présenté ensuite
au Sénat puis à l'Assemblée nationale
fait le chemin normal dans une
démocratie parlementaire la première
ministre Elisabeth borne a réagi à ce
vote et elle a dit qu'il existait une
majorité au Parlement en faveur de cette
réforme des retraites après des
soubresauts notamment l'Assemblée
nationale autour des députés LR est-ce
que vous dites ça y est les républicains
sont aux côtés du gouvernement pour
cette réforme je vais pas parler à la
place des députés de l'Assemblée
nationale je crois que le Sénat apporte
un texte qui reprend les préoccupations
les préoccupations qui ont été exprimées
je pense aussi à la question des petites
retraites je pense à la question des
carrières longues mais n'oublions pas
il y a une étude de très importante de
l'Institut des politiques publiques qui
a démontré que le sujet ce n'était pas
uniquement les carrières longues c'est
dans quelles conditions dans quelles
conditions arriver à un homme et une
femme après sa période de travail pour
envisager sa retraite dans les
meilleures conditions et ça c'est un
apport du Sénat c'est un mot sur la
forme de ces débats et la décision hier
du gouvernement d'utiliser la procédure
dite du vote bloqué est-ce que ce n'est
pas un échec démocratique quand même non
parce que ça s'appelle le vote unique
et donc on s'est exprimé par un vote
mais je rappelle que jusqu'à l'article 9
et débat avait lieu ils ont eu lieu dans
une forme différente mais ils ont eu
lieu et il y a eu je dois dire des
débats des temps de parole des écoutes
sur chacun des amendements merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président du Sénat
d'être venu sur notre plateau après ce
vote de la Haute Assemblée en faveur de
la réforme des retraites et
[Musique]